[Music]
hi
i'm christian wheeler i teach a lot of
courses on the topic of leadership
agility at stanford gsb and these are
five takeaways from my course
spontaneous management
[Music]
in silicon valley a lot of companies
have the motto of failing fast failing
frequently but on a personal level it
can be difficult for us to accept
failure
we often have a fear of looking stupid
in front of other people or making
mistakes but an outsized fear of failure
has negative consequences for us as
leaders a fear of failure can make you
avoid growth situations and it's only
when we are at the outer edge of our
limits when we are encountering that
failure possibility that we are
operating at the peak of our abilities
failure is a step on the path to
learning
secondly dwelling on failure takes you
out of the situation so you can't
respond adaptively to what the context
gives you
we have a motto in the class to be
comfortable being uncomfortable you will
feel anxious in a lot of situations but
if you can learn to ease into that
feeling without dwelling on it you can
respond most adaptively in any context
[Music]
human beings communicate through a wide
array of channels and only one of them
is the verbal channel the words that
people say
most in-person communication happens
through non-verbal signals
it is through these signals that we get
the layers of meaning people's unstated
beliefs their comfort level their
emotions their status and it's critical
for us as leaders to learn how to
interpret these nonverbal signals
but it's also important for us to
understand that we are always giving off
these nonverbal signals whether or not
we intend to
in our class we teach you how to broaden
your range much like an actor might
learn to play different roles so that
you can recruit the non-verbal behaviors
that are most adaptive to you in any
given context
improvisational theater is a foundation
of this class an improvisational theater
is all about storytelling
practically since the dawn of language
human beings have been telling one
another's stories and the narrative
structure is a structure through which
we give context and even our own lives a
sense of meaning purpose and journey
stories are emotional they allow the
listener to develop an empathetic
response to the protagonist and research
shows the stories can be more compelling
than rhetoric and more memorable as well
you may not think of yourself as a
skilled storyteller but you can learn
these techniques stories have a typical
structure and compelling stories have
common elements that can be taught
if you can learn to turn your facts into
stories you can develop a deep and
enduring connection with your audience
[Music]
if you've read anything about improv you
know the first rule of improv is yes and
the yes component means that we're
taking somebody's input and
incorporating it and the and means that
we are building specifically on that
idea and it is through this process that
an improv company can take a simple
suggestion like a relationship between
two people
and end up with a fully creative
dramatic full-length 90-minute play
it is through incorporating others ideas
and building on them that you can end up
in creative places that you never
anticipated many of us are resistant to
yes and type of thinking because we want
to contain the situation we want to have
a sense of control over the direction
that it goes in but when we can learn to
seed some of that control to incorporate
and build on others ideas we can
generate breakthrough innovative
creative solutions
when you learn to embrace spontaneity to
relax into the moment
to be comfortable being uncomfortable
you can be authentic and present in a
moment
when you learn to let go of preconceived
notions you have about yourself to let
go of expectations about others and the
context then you can be fully present
and adaptively respond to what the
moment gives you
this allows you to attend to unspoken
things it allows you to be responsive to
ideas in your environment to see
connections between ideas that others
overlook it allows you to interact
deeply and authentically to build
rapport and achieve your goals
[Music]
yeah you can't be an improviser unless
you are willing to look like a complete
idiot in front of people on an
unpredictable schedule
[Music]
you